and oh are we going to see a result  once again magnus has gone for your  recommendation which  i said  there was no need to but he's gone just  g6  h6 king h7 simplifying handshake draw  yeah it's over we are going to see  our third armageddon match of the day  this time fishy anand will face off  against magnus coulson and vichy anand  has having 10 minutes on the clock  will need to beat magnus in order to  take one and a half points  the players  analyzing away and uh it's nice to kind  of see the players still chatting and  being friendly because after all they do  have a second game to play  yeah  don't give away all your secrets there  magnus probably said yeah yeah actually  seven is ridiculous i'll play bishop c5  in the armageddon like a normal person  not doing